[موسيقى]
اذا المنتخب القطري يخسر بثلاثيه بالهدف
وحيد امام المنتخب السنغال في ثاني
مباريات المونديال للاسف الشديد كان في
بطء بعمليه الانتقال من الدفاع عن الهجوم
كان في بطء بعمليه التعامل والتفكير
واتخاذ القرار والكره مع اللاعب القطري
كان في ايضا تسرع بانه اللاعب بيخلص من
الكره ويرميها الى الامام بطريقه همم يعني
مش مفهومه بكل امانه كان ممكن او كان
الاجداد انه منتخب قطر يلعب على الارض
يمرر كرات بشكل طبيعي جدا ويحاول ابني
هجمه خلال الشوط الاول والشوط الثاني ما
شفنا اي هجمه مفهومه من جانب المنتخب
القطري ما شفنا اي كره ملعوبه من الدفاع
الى الهجوم بشكل سلس وبشكل مدروس وهذا
نتيجه امر واحد فقط
تحضير نفسه
اتمنى اللي شاف فيديو ارفي رونار مدرب
السعوديه وهو يحفز اللاعبين بين شوطي
المباراه انه يعرضوا لنا كيف كيف مدرب
المنتخب القطري فيلكس سانشيز قدر انه يحفز
لاعبي المنتخب القطري في هذه المباراه
لانه في مشكله بعمليه التحفيز في مشكله
بعمليه تحفيز اللاعبين على تقديم ما هو
افضل داخل ارضيه الملعب هل هذا كل ما لدى
المنتخب القطري مستحيل المنتخب القطري
نحنا كنا موجودين بالملعب عام 2019 لما
كان في مباراه امام اليابان في نهائي كاس
اسيا احنا بنعرف شو يعني اداء المنتخب
القطري ولكن شو ناقصه لاعب المنتخب القطري
لحتى يقدم افضل من هذا داخل ارضيه الملعب
الدوري متوقف منذ سبتمبر الماضي بدوري
تحضيرات ربما هذا افضل تحضير لمنتخب مشارك
في كاس العالم على الاطلاق لاعب كوبا
امريكا ولاعب ولاعب تصفيات الاوروبيه يعني
كان على قدم وساق التحضير كان على قدم
وساق للمنتخب القطري ما الذي ينقص منتخب
قطر لتقديم اداء افضل من ذلك اتمنى انه ما
يطلع اي لاعب بالمنتخب القطري ويقول نحن
سوينا اللي علينا لانه يعني انا اسف ولكن
لا انتم ما سويتوا الي عليكم كان في افضل
من ذلك بكثير كان يجب تقديم افضل من ذلك
بكثير كان يجب ان يكون المنتخب القطري في
وضع افضل على الاقل لما بتكون عم بتشارك
بكاس العالم في مسؤوليه امام هذا الجمهور
الحاضر الخلفي الان الذي يغادر الملعب كان
في مسؤوليه اكبر على عاتق لاعبين المنتخب
القطري لتقديم افضل من ذلك اليوم للظهور
بشكل افضل من ذلك ولكن للاسف سؤال اخر
الفلكس سانشيز التبديلات حتى الدقيقه 74
ليش
محمد مونتاري يعني اليوم لاعب امام منتخب
السنغال منتخب باطوال عنده مدافعين طوال
مثل كوليبالي ومثل جيكوبس وحتى لو لاعب
سيسيه كان راح يكون لاعب طويل ايضا
الاعتماد على محمد مونتاري
متاخر جدا
المباراه الاولى من مباراه الاكوادور كان
اللاعب الافضل هجوميا عند المنتخب القطري
ليش التاخير بالاعتماد عليها حسن الهدوس
لاعب كبير كلنا مقتنعيم حسن الهدوس لاعب
كبير ولديه الكثير ليقدم الكره القطريه
وقدم الكثيره للكره القطريه ولكن
حصل الهدوس بطيء نوعا ما في التعامل مع
الكرات اللي بمنتصف الملعب لذلك كان يجب
الاعتماد على محمد مونتاري ليكون لاعب
محطه لما تلعب كراتك الطولي اللي انت ما
تمت عليها من الشوط الاول لازم يكون في
عندك لاعب محطه وهذا اللاعب كان غير موجود
لحتى يريح لك الكره للمعز علي ولا اكرم
عفيف والهؤلاء اللاعبين ولكن كرات طوليه
عشوائيه بدون اي هدف يعني هذا امر مستغرب
بكل امانه يعني فارجو انه تتدارك او
يتدارك المنتخب القطري الامور في اخر
مباراه ليظهر بشكل افضل ربما في اخر
مباراه له في هذه البطوله ما بعرف فرص
التاهل قد تكون قائمه حسب الحسابات ولكن
اعتقد ان الموضوع صار الشبه مستحيل على
منتخب قطر انه هو يوصل للدور الثاني كل
التوفيق في البطولات القادمه يجب على
اللاعبين انه يكتبه الخبره لازم يكون
الامانه يكتسبوا خبره اكبر من هذه
المشاركه ويطلعوا بالفائده الكبيره منها
حتى يعرفوا كيف يتعاملوا مع البطولات
المقبله بكل امانه اعتقد ف انتهى مع
المنتخب القطري يجب انه يقال الان او انه
خلاص يتشكر على اداؤه على الشيء اللي قبله
على مدار السنوات الماضيه مع قطر وناتي
بمدرب جديد بفكر جديد بعقليه جديده ربما
يطور اداء المنتخب القطري ويكون لديه
افكار وطريقه تحفيز افضل بالنسبه للاعبي
المنتخب القطري في قادم المباريات هاردك
لجمهور القطري لجمهور البلد المضيف
وبالمناسبه هذه قد تكون واحده من اسوا
مشاركات همم الدول المضيفه في تاريخ كاس
العالم لم تكن اسوء على الاطلاق ولكن هي
كانت المشاركه الاولى وبتاع الامر مفهوم
ومعذورين عليه اللي بلوم الجمهور انا مش
شايف في اي يوم على الجمهور الجمهور اذا
انت حمست باداءك وقدمت اللي عليك داخل
ارضيه الملعب وقديت بتضحكي وبينت الروح
اللي عندك وبيات انك عم بتلعب على كل كره
جمهور راح يتحمس معك ولكن لما تكون مبين
انك مش عم تقدم كل اللي عندك ومش عم تعطي
كل الموجود عندك وكل همم القدرات الموجوده
عندك
روعتك بالشكل الصحيح جمهور ما راح يتفاعل
معك وراح يغادر الملعب مبكرا مثل ما شفنا
في مباراه اليوم مره اخرى هاردك المنتخب
القطري والف مبروك لجمهور السنغال هذا
الفوز المهم السنغال الان عينها على
التاهل في مباراه الاكوادور اللي اعتقد
راح تكون واحده من اقوى مباريات الدوري
الاول في هذه البطوله
[موسيقى]